one of the things that I learned that
while I was going through this was the
meaning of the name Israel because Jacob
eventually gets named Israel and and I'm
jumping ahead a little bit to the next
lecture but Israel and so he's also the
father of Israel and the father of the
twelve sons who make up the 12 tribes of
Israel
but what Israel means is he who
struggles with God and that's such an
interesting idea because it's a again a
psychological idea and that's why I said
earlier that it isn't obvious in the Old
Testament what it means to believe in
God because what Jacob does is struggle
with God and I think that that's a
really good characterization of an
ethical life because if you're trying to
lead an ethical life that's what you're
doing is you're you're struggling like
blind belief isn't helpful because you
don't know what you're believing in like
it's just not that helpful but if you're
possessed by by the desire to orient
yourself properly but also confused by
the by the existential structure of the
world which we all are then then what
you're doing when you're trying to
orient yourself properly in life is
struggling ethically and Jacob actually
gets quite hurt he wrestles with God
literally and God dislocates his his his
thigh and so you know the idea there is
watch the hell out right the thing that
you're contending with is powerful
although you can contend with it that's
the thing that's so interesting but you
know you do it at some genuine peril
which i think is exactly right but the
idea that Israel so there's Israel the
state let's say in Israel the promised
land and all of that but there's this
more important idea which is again a
psychological idea which is the State of
Israel which is the promised land is the
state that everyone who wrestles with
God exists in and that's not happy naive
belief in you know an eternally blessed
afterlife it's not that it's not a wish
fulfillment it's it's it's to be
actively engaged in life in the
difficulties of life right and trying to
find the path because that's what
wrestling with God is it's trying to
find the path and that seems to me what
belief means fundamentally in the Old
Testament perhaps and
New Testament as well is that belief is
expressed in trying to find the path and
that's an ethical struggle and it's a
real struggle it's the struggle of life
so as long as you're willing to engage
in that struggle then hypothetically you
have the Divine behind you and so I
believe that I think that's true because
the other thing I see is that the people
who set things right so that yeah the
the horrible forces of cosmic
destruction don't do us in the people
who are trying to set things right are
the ones that are struggling ethically
and so and that there is a redemptive
element to that and I don't think
there's any way of being cynical about
that so well so thank you will
[Applause]